continúa El Avance de los manifestantes
hacia Lima en oposición al gobierno de
Dina boluarte en cusco decenas de
personas bloquearon caminos en su
travesía rumbo a la capital peruana
pidiendo por la salida del actual
mandataria y para el cierre del Congreso
nosotros en ningún momento podemos ni
siquiera mencionarle como presidente
Ella es una Usurpadora traicionera que
está actuando a costas de la población
ella es provinciana como nosotros pero
eso no vemos Nosotros por eso mismo ella
es Usurpadora traidora del pueblo dentro
de sus reclamos los campesinos reprochan
la postura violenta a las fuerzas de
seguridad en un contexto donde más de
medio centenar de manifestantes han
perdido la vida
la policía el ejército ha salido con una
sola orden y es matarnos no es un no es
un peruano no son dos ya son más de 50
peruanos que están muertos son niños
adolescentes
abuelitos no no somos terroristas lo
como ellos nos indican
con banderas y pancartas interrumpieron
caminos según ellos la única metodología
con la que el gobierno puede tomarlos en
cuenta nuestra voz como el campesino se
siente cierran un paso
cierran del paso es nuestra voz de
protesta se siente nuestro reclamo se
siente es por este razón que nosotros
seguimos en pie de lucha hasta que se
solucione hasta que dé un paso al
costado la señora presidenta
los levantamientos continúan en
distintas regiones del territorio
algunos han terminado en violencia y
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad este jueves el aeropuerto de
la segunda ciudad más grande de Perú
Arequipa fue asaltado y las operaciones
suspendidas